Dang it. This is too real. I want something I could do
online now guys. DONG.
Let's start things off with a Tetris
Overload. 'Muse13NJ' showed me this first person
Tetris.
When you turn a piece, so does your perspective.
It's fun, but 'Dixavd' would rather
prank you with Portal Tetris.
Ah, you know, this isn't going to end well.
Or, really,
in debt all.
'LeatbouldersTV' brought us Tetris
Laps, where just like Mario Tetris you
arrange blocks to make the level
more navigable. Now, as you play, you unlock each next level.
But you could just cheat like 'BloodsailAdmiralTdk'
who showed off ArcadePreHacks.com, where you can find flash games you like to play
except all the levels are already
unlocked right off the bat. 'MrDeagleking'
blew my mind
with browser pong.
Why play with moving dots and
fixed part of your window, when you can play with windows.
But now, let's toogle like 'tanos1998.'
This search engine takes a word you give it and makes a picture of that word
using the word itself.
For science,
check out the periodic table of videos
where the University of Nottingham gives
you a video
with info and experiments for every element.
Not enough about you?
'AliRex27' recommended
a site that takes your name and displays it as
elements. 'Vince8745' brought us this simple beauty
of a game called
'And Everything Started to Fall.'
In this game you climb through your life
to survive.
And as you survive you actually grow up -
first to child, then a teenager, and so on.
Wo...wait.
How quickly can you type the alphabet?
'Thecheatlord999' showed me this guy
whose work is awesome. His planetarium
lets you pick a region of the world,
click through time and then check out
where the Moon will be,
what phase it'll be in, you can even mouse over a star to get its information.
And if you own 3D glasses like these,
check out his
anaglyph drawing tool, where you can draw
pictures on the screen itself
and then navigate around in
three-dimensional space.
On the manly side is 'JakeGordonTV's' message
about balls dropping. This chrome
experiment lets you draw lines to bounce
falling balls
right inside your browser.
Finally, trip out with 'misterturtle1998's' suggestion
for
this game that scares me.
But that's not all.
On Friday I'm gonna have a brand new
episode of Vsauce Leanback.
It's going to be a really fun one.
But right now, go check out Kevin's little piece of
investigative journalism
about everything you need to know about jetpacks.
It's awesome, subscribe to our channels.
And as always,
thanks for watching.